israel avanza en su agresivo plan de
inmunización de la población allí las
personas mayores de 35 años podrán
recibir la primera dosis del fármaco
contra el cob y 19 con ello las
autoridades del país esperan cumplir con
la meta de vacunar a una gran parte de
la población antes de la primavera
bien las noticias que hay permiso para
que las personas mayores de 35 años
vengan y se vacunen abrir la aplicación
y pedir la cita por suerte había para
hoy y no para mañana me apresuré y pedí
la segunda cita automáticamente y me
acaban y está todo se anegan automatic
pero mientras que israel avanza para
contener la propagación del virus
la vacuna todavía no llega a los
palestinos en los territorios ocupados
de cisjordania y gaza en ramala la
capital de cisjordania los hospitales
experimentan un repunte en el número de
contagios la autoridad palestina lucha
para asegurar el suministro de la vacuna
rusa sputnik ve y hay voces que instan a
israel a compartir sus vacunas
los israelíes han tenido un plan exitoso
de vacunación sin embargo los palestinos
no cuándo
la conexión entre palestinos e israelíes
no puedes vacunar a una parte de la
población y no a la otra y pensar que
estarás a salvo el texto del vice la onu
ha instado israel para que contribuye en
la respuesta a las necesidades del
pueblo palestino en los territorios
ocupados mientras los palestinos están
sin vacunas casi 2,8 millones de
israelíes han recibido la primera dosis
y la mitad de ellos una segunda